hi everyone thank you for having me my
name is max
guenis and i'm uh the founder and
president of the ubi center
we are a think tank and i'm excited to
share with you
what we're about and some analyses that
we've done using github
python and jupiter so first of all
who are we we are think tank and our
mission is to produce
open source research that informs a
robust policy debate around
the idea of universal basic income
and this is a policy idea that everyone
in this society
would get an equal amount a cash grant
from the government
usually on monthly basis
and especially excited to share with you
because our origins are really rooted
in open source personally i worked at
google as a data scientist
for most of my career and throughout
that time i became increasingly
interested
in economics economic policy poverty
and how policies like ubi could
improve situations like poverty and
inequality
but i didn't really feel i had the tools
to explore that until i found a group
that
that works on this specifically called
the policy simulation library
and this is a group of economists that
builds tools open source
all in python to understand public
policy making especially economic policy
so i became really interested in using
these tools for some of my ideas
and also contributing to them long story
short i left google
pursued my graduate degree in economics
and started the ubi center about a year
and a half ago
our first paper our sort of humble
beginnings really rode the wave of andre
yang who was a
presidential candidate for democratic
primary and he focused his campaign
around
a ub version of ubi he called the
freedom dividend
it was a thousand dollars a month given
to every adult funded largely by a
value-added tax as well as some changes
to
other taxes and welfare programs um so
we did the only distributional analysis
out there of this policy um showing that
is
in fact quite progressive with the
bottom decile over doubling their
income and the top decile losing out
now we have researchers all over the
world looking at ubi from a variety of
angles in the us canada australia the uk
and pakistan obviously open source has
enabled this kind of collaboration which
has been really fruitful
and exciting a few of the projects i'll
talk about today
include simulating a child allowance
across u.s states so this is basically a
ubi for kids
as well as comparing uh the 600 per week
emergency unemployment benefits this was
part of the pandemic relief package
in the u.s to a budget neutral ubi
and finally some dynamic macro
macroeconomic modeling
of ubi so first on child allowances
i think the background here that's
pretty important is that research has
been very consistent
showing that child poverty has really
deleterious effects on a variety of
outcomes
educational attainment lifetime earnings
health
both even child mortality as well as
long-term
life expectancy so a lot of countries
especially in europe
have enacted a child allowance so for
example finland and ireland
give every parent a monthly stipend
every month for every child that they
have
and it has bipartisan appeal in the u.s
because on the conservative side they
like the
family focus on the liberal side it's
more about reducing child poverty
and it's been actually a part of the
democrats heroes act which is this
the round two version of the kobit nine
team recovery after the
the cares act so what we've done
is we've simulated different levels of
child allowances
um here i'll show you a deficit funded
version where we also have some
tax funded versions and it's pretty much
the same story
so for example california today has the
highest child poverty rate in the
country
21 and you can see how as you implement
a child allowance the child poverty rate
continues to fall
so for example at 300 dollars per month
it has fallen to
10.5 percent it's been cut in half and
if you have 500
per month child allowance child poverty
falls by two-thirds to seven percent
we also have a tool where you can select
any given state
so the u.s or any other state and it
shows the child poverty rate as a
function of
the child allowance as well as the
overall poverty rate uh some other
analyses as well
are part of this deep dive into child
allowances
so this is i think important from a
policy level because you could imagine a
child allowance that's
national there could also be states that
try to implement child allowances to
reduce
child poverty in their own state and
this empowers people to understand the
facts of those policies
so some of the tools we used uh plotly
for
all the visualization also micro df is a
package that we created to work with
microeconomic data
which involves a lot of weighted
calculations that aren't built into
a lot of the default python data
analysis packages
this is all published with a tool called
jupiter book which
we've been really enjoying working with
and it's all hosted on github so totally
open source
next analysis we uh ran is um
looking at the 600 per week unemployment
benefits that ran from april to july
2020
this was one of the most controversial
also a very generous
program that the u.s had as part of the
cares act so
we simulated extending the policy which
um
there's been a lot of appetite for um
comparing to
also a budget neutral ubi so giving
everyone a smaller amount
but with the same aggregate cost looking
backwards from 2009 to 2018 where we
have
the best data on poverty this was a
little bit more involved in terms of
technical analysis because it required
modeling the unemployment benefits as
taxable so we use policy simulation
libraries tax calculator for that as
well
and our results essentially showed that
compared to extending the
um the unemployment benefit
we looked at two alternatives so that
extending it was the gray line
and this is looking at the change in the
poverty rate we also looked at the
payroll tax cut which has been a
idea floated by president trump at the
time and two versions of a ubi
so the dark blue is a ubi to everyone
light blue is
payment to adults only and these are all
budget neutrals so the same total cost
but the payment to everybody actually
reduces poverty 20
more compared to the unemployment
benefit and this was in 2009 which
really has the most similar economic
characteristics to
today in terms of very high unemployment
really poor economic circumstances
same results if you look at the poverty
gap which is another measure of poverty
that
counts how far below the poverty line
different people are
and also inequality so sort of on every
distributional
metric a ubi is actually more
progressive than extending the
unemployment benefit
largely because there's a lot of people
who are outside the labor force who
don't benefit from the unemployment or
people who are low wage who also don't
benefit
finally we looked at dynamic
macroeconomic modeling which would be
really important if
ubi were to get to the point where
there's a law a legislation that's
proposed
so any major reform which ubi would
definitely meet that bar
it would require probably a large number
of tax reforms as well
is scored by the congressional budget
office and potentially the
joint committee on taxation so there are
some non-government models that do
dynamic modeling as well penn morton
budget model is one
and there's also the policy simulation
libraries ogusa
open source model all these do what's
called overlapping generations models
where every person in the economy is
optimizing for
their lifetime utility so how much they
want to consume in each period or
request to their kids they're basically
going to make
choices in every period around their
labor force participation how much they
save
how much they consume and all this
affects
aggregate metrics like gdp labor
labor supply investment etc
so we found some interesting results
when we simulated ubi for example
uh consumption increased most for the
poor when they're young
and the rich when they're old um and
overall it's progressive
the this was based on a pre-experimental
implementation of ubi in og usa based on
taxes
and we found some problems with that so
i'm really excited that we now have a
research assistant
who is implementing ubi directly into
this program so
we're giving back to the open source
community that way
so our major goals for the future of
course are our number one one is to
inform policy makers and the public
about the economics of ubi
but not too far behind that we really
want to build and contribute to open
source
economics tools so contributing to
groups like the policy simulation
library
as well as our own tools like micro df
and to demonstrate how open source can
improve
policy analysis so that other think
tanks or maybe new think tanks like ours
can consider the approach to not just in
terms of short term getting more
eyeballs and
you know reviews on different analyses
but hopefully recruiting people like me
who may have an interest in economics
and policy making
either if they want to change their
whole career or just have a small
bite-sized project that they can get
taste for the realm i think that'll
really improve
the whole domain you'll improve open
source and ultimately
the public who are most affected by
our public policy so with that uh thank
you very much and i look forward to your
questions
you